hello everyone and welcome to the
champion showdown the chess 960 edition
where
some very strong players will compete in
a double round robin uh
in the chess 960 version of chess and
the first game
uh that we're showing is a game from
round one alireza ferruga
and like it says on the thumbnail uh as
alireza is 17 and
kasparov is 57 there's a 40 years
difference between the two of them so
that's really really insane
something you will not see in pretty
much any other sport but um
the game is just really awesome so uh
without further ado let's check it out
uh the time format is
rapid uh players have a 20 second uh 20
minutes
per player plus i think it's a 10
seconds per move
i will have to check though and uh well
uh it's very interesting if you're like
me i didn't enjoy chess 960
uh in in the beginning but then i
realized it's basically just a
new move or a new new position already
as of move one and
bro and after a few moves players just
castle and after they castle it's just
more or less like like a regular
position and for those of you who are
new to chess 960
uh and you might think but how do you
castle here
it's actually super simple and we're
going to reach castling within a few
moves so we're going to explain it
once we reach it so without further ado
for the second time
uh furuja with the white pieces opens
with g3
sorry about that uh and yeah it's not
like in the previous champions showdown
in 2019 where players had like half an
hour to study the position with their
seconds but without the engines
uh here players get only three minutes
before the game starts to analyze the
position
so they're going to spend a bit more
time during the opening phases of the
game
and also uh sorry i'm talking a bit more
but this is the first video in the
tournament so i tend to do that
sometimes
i tweeted this uh some six hours ago uh
uh regarding how will kasparov do in the
champions showdown i wrote kaparov
uh as twitter does not have the edit
button uh
so 50 of you guys uh said that he will
score about 50 36 percent of you said it
he will score below 50
and 13.8 percent of you said that it
he's going to
win first place easy so let's see how
how uh
it's going down so g3 by ferruja makes
sense uh opening up the diagonal for the
queen and the light square bishop and
kasparov strikes in the center which you
should do
if your opponent opens uh with with the
flank attack
uh we have d4 by ferruja and now g6
kasparov does the same opening diagonals
for the queen and the bishop we have
knight to c3
uh furuja developing everything in order
to execute e4 and
c6 strengthening the d5 pawn and at some
point kasparov will also uh want to play
e5
uh we have knights to b3 and now af5
because part of
uh developing uh to prevent furuja from
executing e4
uh and f3 here if you just spend a bit
more time than kasparov he
uh spent some four minutes whereas
kasparov spent only two minutes
but it's because players don't get
enough time to study the position
beforehand so they have to spend a bit
more
while they're actually playing and here
kasparov could go for the immediate e5
but
uh it's uh mostly just breaking the
tensioner without any serious gains so
instead he just continues developing
knight
to c7 he wants to bring his knights into
the game and now
firuja needs to decide whether e4 right
away is an option
it is but again uh it serves no purpose
other than opening up the position
bishop g4
attacks the rook let's say rook d2 and
while it is playable
uh it's uh hard to decide whether e5
here is a plus or a minus four
white will it be an overextended pawn
will cc in the future be a problem for
white
uh and so on so furuga also keeps the
pressure continues developing
queen f2 and knights the e6 by kasparov
we have bishop to d2 and now knight to
d7 continuing development the knight is
coming to b6
and the c4 and here is the moment where
firuja castles uh so now you might think
but how are you gonna castle
well it's important that there are no
pieces in between the
the king and the rook uh so of course
you can castle
and castling is super easy because when
you perform the castle you just move the
king here
and what you get is that the king and
rook will
uh end up in the exact same position
where they would end up if you were
playing regular chess
so here it doesn't matter if the king
was here and the rook was here
if you castled they'd still look like
this after castling was completed so
it's super simple
with knight to b6 kasparov continues uh
getting the his knight to the c4 square
and
a nice prophylactic king to b1 queen to
f6
putting a nice uh putting a lot of
pressure here on the d4 pawn
uh and here you could defend it with e3
but ferruja wants to
be flexible with the e pawn so instead
just bishop c1 now uh
everything is nicely defended and also
if the position opens up the bishop
might be a useful defender of the b2
pawn
and knight the sea for now and uh again
ferocious took some
more time to uh consider everything in
the position as he already is down to
eight minute and 30 seconds whereas
kasparov is up to 12 minutes
and 40 seconds uh if you remember last
year in his match against fabiano corona
kasparov had a lot of winning positions
but he he didn't have enough time to
convert them so i guess here he's
pushing himself to play a little bit
faster
rook g to e1 now finally preparing that
e4 and here kasparov just castles king's
side and as you can see there's nothing
in between the rook and the king
and the two of them will end up in the
exact same position where they would if
they were playing regular chess
so queen the g1 uh fiduciary doesn't
want uh
his queen on the f file uh after
executing this
e4 idea but now kasparov doesn't allow
it he pushes
f4 and now he says okay if you push e4 i
can always capture alpha
and it's not going to work my phone is
listening
to me uh so g captures on f4 we have
knight captures and now
e3 and kasparov needs to decide now
where to go with the knight whether he's
going to go to e6 the h5 or the h3
so all the all the ideas have their
merits but the knight the h3
seems to be the most aggressive one but
there is an issue what if the knight
well what if f4 is played and the knight
gets stuck there uh without
any serious escape routes uh but okay uh
kasparov took some three minutes for
this move so
he calculated everything out queen g3 as
first queen is under attack queen to g5
and now uh while you could trade queens
here this would probably just help
black for example if f4 you're stuck
with a with a weak e3 pawn and you have
to do something 96
uh it's not nothing nothing great is
happening here for white so instead
rook to f1 firuja adds another defender
to the f3 pawn
uh and here kasparov traits characters
captures and then now
e5 finally and here ferocious does
something that
i'm guessing kasparov was hoping for he
trades in the center with captures
captures and now pushes
f4 and while he does grab a bit more
space here
kasparov just uh moves the bishop uh and
the problem is that
now uh ferruja is stuck with the
backwards e3 pawn and here kasparov
has to decide whether to move the bishop
back or to trade on c3
yes he would give up the bishop pair but
he would mess up first pawn structure
which means this knight would be a
monster here
there would be no pawns able to kick it
away from there and still
stuck with this weak e3 pawn however
kasparov loves the bishop
pair uh so he just goes back bishop to
g7
and now rugby beat e1 again just wanting
to to push that pawn
first down to two minutes and 30 seconds
because power of at 4 minutes and now
kasparov
postpones a ferocious e4 thrust by going
g5
so bishop to g2 it's uh it's a
nice attacking move uh the knight that
doesn't really have anywhere else to go
but it's hard to trap the knight rook h1
it will never work because you always
have this knight to f2 idea
so here kasparov has the the very sneaky
knight the a3 check move
he didn't play it but i will show it as
it is tricky now you have to capture the
knight because if you move the king you
lose the c2 pawn so you have to capture
and now bishop captures here
attacking the the rook and after a trade
here bishop d2 captures captures now d4
is very strong for kasparov he breaks
through and um
he will have a very pleasant game
however he played bishop to f5
and now he just gave uh he gave
basically ferugia a target and furuja
goes for it knight to d4
and now kasparov doesn't move the bishop
rather he captures on d4 and now this is
weird
uh for two reasons because if uh
well he could have captured on c3 and
the mess of furuja's pawn structure
rather kasparov captures on d4 and he
fixes
he he doesn't only not mess up his pawn
structure on the queen side but he also
fixes his
uh pawn structure in the center as now
firuja no longer has
his weak e3 pawn but you know you
uh better that than to
waste more time and then struggle later
so here he fixes ferocious problems a
little bit for him
and uh executes the g4 now the bishop
will also be able to move as the knight
is defended by the pawn and in the
future he might have ideas of h5h4
and creating some some passwords here so
b3
kicking away kasparov's knight knight to
d6 with ideas of maybe going to e4
uh and bishop to a3 now here firuja
doesn't want to allow it because ferruja
wants the open d
file for his rooks and he will rather
give up the dark square bishop than to
allow this knight to land on e4
so rook f7 unpinning but now rook to e5
uh now the rook is on a very nice square
hopefully the other book will also uh
join in and here if you go in it's uh
it's a bit too early because here just
bishop captures the knight bishop
captures
captures captures and uh well after the
captures the the rook can just uh
uh after c3 let's say defend this and
this is now an extremely weak pawn
uh so instead with h5 by kasparov
now preparing h4 probably first uh with
some assistance from the rook king to b2
and now king to g7 both players start
improving the position of their kings
and now bishop captures on d6 ferruja
gets rid of it
as he is already down to a minute on the
clock and he does want to continually
continuously calculate what happens if
the knight lands on e4 at some point
so rook captures and now knights the d1
and like i said one minute for first
some three minutes for casparo and
kasparov could go for
something like rook to h6 followed by h4
create a nice pass pawn here
however he decides to go for rook to e6
instead and offer a rook trade
uh ferruja instantly goes and knights
the e3 puts pressure on the bishop and
kasparov trades rook captures on e5
d captures this gives firuja a nice pass
pawn and king to g6 now
and here it's a very tough position but
also firuja is very low on time
however he does have a very very
interesting idea of just bringing the
king into the game
king c3 king d4 and the black can't
really afford to push the pawns to stop
uh
the white king because well the the d5
pawn just falls and everything falls
so here king c3 is incredibly strong but
firuja played c4 and now he
well now he basically uh returns the
favor as now
gary has a lot of good moves so here
kasparov pushes d4
now he has a pass pawn knight captures
with king captures and
rook to e1 preparing to push the pass
pawn but now
h4 kasparov ready to create a passer of
his own
bishop to e4 check uh and here uh what
do you do there's only one move for
kasparov and if you go to e6 which you
must uh well then
you will have some problems king e6 and
now firuja instantly goes f5 with
check and although this looks incredible
because it forces the king into some
very nasty discoveries and firujo will
win
the rook on f7 it also uh
well bears its own set of problems so
kasparov does go for it king captures on
e5
uh with bishop to d5 a discovered check
also connects with the rook here
king f6 and now bishop captures on f7
and now
feel free to pause the video and uh find
the winning idea for kasparov while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
winning idea
either of them and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
h capture sun g3 this is incredibly fast
and incredibly efficient
uh the move kasparov played this king
captures on f7 which is also winning but
takes a a bit more to grind out to the
full point
because here now the threat is just this
and
white will have to give up the rook
there's nothing to be done after he
saves the bishop
g2 you're probably going to go after the
pawns here like this and
of course you can't move this one
because you lose this but now just bring
the queen into the game
and after bishop captures you play
something like knight f3 and with the
two uh two pass pawns you're going to
win this one it's a completely winning
game for kasparov
uh the move cause power played is also
winning but it requires a bit more
grinding
uh rook to e2 by ferruja now preparing
to block the pawns with rogue g2 but now
h captures on g3 rogue g2 going after
the pawns
and now king f6 we have rook captures
and king captures on f5
we have c5 uh not allowing uh
kasparov to connect to the pawns here
and now king to f4 we have rook to d3
going after this pawn
but kasparov of course giving up the
pawn he just pushes his pass pawn g3
captures on d4 with check king e3 and
the rook
sorry king the e3 attacks the rook and
rook to h
for now and while g2 is sufficient for a
win but you have to calculate what if
rook captures with
check king goes here and then that you
have a winning endgame there's no reason
to do this as fiducia is incredibly low
on time
knight f2 and now everything is nicely
defended this is defended this is
defended this is defender
this is defended and the pawn is coming
forward so rook h7 by ferruja and here
kasparov just played
g2 and it was in this position that
alireza faruja resigned the game
and the first game goes to gary kasparov
uh who
uh who is off to to a great start we'll
see what what happens uh
from here and how will the tournament go
for him and how will of course
the tournament go for for young alireza
uh so yeah
that's uh the game i do hope you enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank
alexander uh first of all
and james patrick for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the champions showdown
cheering up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and i
forgot uh of course
white resigns because after you do this
just king of three and there's no
nothing to be done here uh you will
either block the rook and then promote
the pawn to a queen or white will have
to give up the rook and then you're just
winning up a full piece
uh so yeah thank you all and i will see
you soon